THAT UPDATE.
>>> MEANWHILE, WASHINGTON, D.C.,
THE MAYOR THERE ANNOUNCED THAT
ALL STAFF AND STUDENTS MUST SHOW
A NEGATIVE COVID TEST BEFORE
RETURNING TO SCHOOL NEXT WEEK.
PEDIATRIC HOSPITALIZATIONS
CONTINUE TO GROW AND MANY
PARENTS ARE WONDERING HOW TO
KEEP THEIR KIDS FROM GETTING
SICK.
SO, TO ADDRESS THIS, THE CITY
HAS REVAMPED ITS COVID TESTING
POLICIES TO TRY TO KEEP KIDS IN
SCHOOL.
CNN'S ALEXANDRA FIELD JOINS US
NOW.
WHAT'S THE NEW TESTING PLAN,
ALEXANDRA.
>> HEY, THERE, ALISYN, THE IDEA
IS TO CATCH CASES MORE QUICKLY
BUT ALSO WANT TO PUT KIDS IN THE
CLASS FASTER.
THE SCHOOLS REALLY ARE THE
SAFEST PLACE TO BE.
THE NEW TESTING PLAN AIMED AT
KEEPING IT THAT WAY.
WHAT THEY'RE DOING, THEY'RE
RELYING ON AT-HOME TEST KITS.
THEY SAY THEY'LL BE GIVEN TWO
KITS PER DAY FOR SEVEN DAYS TO
ALL THE CHILDREN IN THAT
CLASSROOM, IN ORDER TO GET BACK
IN THE CLASSROOM, YOU'LL HAVE TO
BE ASYMPTOMATIC AND HAVE TWO
NEGATIVE TESTS IN A ROW AND YOU
CAN THEN RETURN THE NEXT DAY.
THIS IS A BALANCING ACT.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
VIEWING THIS.
TO TRY AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO
IDENTIFY THE CASES AND TAKE CARE
OF THEM THROUGH THE TESTING
MECHANISMS.
ON TOP OF THE RAPID AT-HOME
TESTS, THEY'RE ALSO GOING TO BE
DOUBLING THE NUMBER OF PCR TESTS
THAT THEY PERFORM UNTIL CITY
SCHOOLS AS ANOTHER LAYER OF
PROTECTION HERE.
THE MAYOR ELECT SAYING THE
SCHOOLS ARE THE SAFEST PLACES
FOR THE KIDS TO BE.
AND THIS JUST PROVES THAT THE
CITY IS COMMITTED TO KEEPING
KIDS IN THE CLASSROOM, EVEN
AMIDST A SURGE THAT HAS LED TO A
RISING NUMBER OF CASES NOT JUST
IN ADULTS, BUT, OF COURSE,
CHILDREN BUT ALSO THIS RISING
NUMBER OF HOSPITALIZATIONS, IT'S
SOMETHING THAT THE CITY IS
EXPERIENCING FIRST HAND.
A FIVE-FOLD INCREASE IN
PEDIATRIC HOSPITALIZATIONS IN
NEW YORK CITY IN JUST THE LAST
THREE WEEKS.
IT'S ALARMING WHEN PARENTS HEAR
THAT.
BUT, ALISYN, WE ALSO HAVE TO
KEEP IN MIND, THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN HOSPITALIZED.
WHILE IT'S GOING UP REMAINS
RELATIVELY SMALL RELATIVE TO THE
NUMBER OF ADULTS WITH COVID.
>> WE ALSO HAVE TO FIND OUT WHAT
THEIR SYMPTOMS ONCE
HOSPITALIZED, HOW BAD IT IS IN
THAT WAVE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
WITH ME OUR TWO DOCTORS ON THE
FRONT LINE, WE HAVE DR. CLAUDIA
OHIOAN, SHE'S A PEDIATRIC
INFECTIOUS DISEASE SPECIAL AND
DR. DAVID KIMBERLIN AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF ALABAMA AT
BIRMINGHAM.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING HERE,
DR. HOYEN, AS WE HEARD, MILLIONS
OF KIDS ARE SCHEDULED TO GO BACK
TO SCHOOL FIVE DAYS FROM NOW.
IS THAT A GOOD IDEA?
>> AT THIS POINT, AS I THINK WAS
JUST NOTED, THERE'S A LOT OF
VARIABILITY AROUND WHAT
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE COUNTRY
ARE SEEING.
I KNOW HERE IN NORTHEAST OHIO,
WE'RE A LITTLE BIT BEHIND PLACES
LIKE NEW YORK, NEW JERSEY,
HOUSTON, IN THAT WE WERE STILL
KIND OF GETTING OVER OUR DELTA
SURGE, SINCE WE WERE THE LAST TO
SURGE WITH DELTA.
AS WE ARE NOW COMING INTO THIS
OMICRON VARIANT SURGE.
AND SO, I THINK THAT, AGAIN, WE
KNOW HOW TO KEEP CHILDREN SAFE
IN SCHOOL.
WE KNOW THAT MASKING IS
EFFECTIVE.
AND IF, YOU KNOW, KIDS ARE
SYMPTOMATIC, OF COURSE, THEY
SHOULD STAY HOME.
IF THEY'VE HAD AN EXPOSURE.
IF YOU'RE ABLE TO DO TESTING,
AGAIN, THERE ARE MANY LAYERS
THAT WE CAN ADD TO KEEP CHILDREN
IN SCHOOL, AS WE MOVE THROUGH
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS.
AS WE KNOW, IT'S NOT ONLY THE
SAFEST PLACE, BUT IT'S THE PLACE
THAT THEY NEED TO BE.
THE LAST TWO YEARS HAVE REALLY
TAKEN A TOLL ON OUR CHILDREN.
AND SO, WE ALL NEED TO DO WHAT
WE CAN, WHETHER THAT'S GETTING
VACCINATED AND MAKING SURE WE'RE
MASKING.
HERE IN OHIO, THE OHIO
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
TODAY ACTUALLY SENT A LETTER TO
THE GOVERNOR.
AND TO ALL OF THE SCHOOLS'
SUPERINTENDENTS.
YOU KNOW, THANKS THOSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WHO ARE CONTINUING TO
MASK.
AND ASKING RESPECTFULLY, THAT AS
WE ARE BRINGING KIDS BACK TO
SCHOOL IN THE MIDDLE OF, YOU
KNOW, RISING NUMBER OF OMICRON
HERE IN OHIO, THAT THEY ALSO
CONSIDER HAVING MASKING IN THOSE
SCHOOLS.
>> YEAH, I KNOW A LOT OF PLACES
IN OHIO HAVE DROPPED THE MASK
MANDATES.
DR. KIMBERLIN, YOU'RE IN
ALABAMA, DO YOU THINK AS YOU
HEARD FROM DR. HOYEN, AND ALEX
FIELD, SAYING SCHOOLS ARE THE
SAFEST PLACE TO BE, WITH THIS
RISE, EXPONENTIAL RISE IN CASES
RIGHT NOW, DO YOU THINK THE
SCHOOLS ARE THE SAFEST PLACES
FOR KIDS TO BE?
>> WELL, MUCH OF WHAT WE KNOW,
OBVIOUSLY, IS BASED ON OUR PRIOR
EXPERIENCE.
AND OMICRON IS BRAND-NEW.
SO, I THINK WE HAVE TO START BY
RECOGNIZING THAT OMICRON IS AN
ENTITY THAT WE WILL BE LEARNING
A LOT MORE ABOUT OVER THESE NEXT
HANDFUL OF WEEKS.
NOW, THAT SAID, I THINK YOU'VE
GOT TO DRAW ON THE EXPERIENCES
YOU'VE HAD IN THE PAST.
AND WE SIMPLY HAVE SEEN OVER AND
OVER AGAIN THAT SCHOOLS HAVE
BEEN OPEN SAFELY WITH PRIOR
VARIANTS OF THE VIRUS, AND THE
ORIGINAL VIRUS.
AND REALLY SPREAD WITHIN SCHOOLS
CAN REFLECT THE BROADER SPREAD
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY.
BUT THEY'RE NOT REALLY THE
STARTING OR HOT SPOTS FOR
SPREADING WITHIN THE COMMUNITY,
GENERALLY SPEAKING.
SO, THAT'S POINT NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, WE HAVE A COUPLE OF
REALLY GOOD STUDIES RIGHT NOW,
CALIFORNIA AND I BELIEVE
ILLINOIS TAKING AN APPROACH OF
TEST TO STAY BASICALLY.
SO WHAT YOU DO THERE, SIMILAR TO
WHAT NEW YORK IS TRYING A
VARIATION ON.
AND THAT IS TO BE TESTED, IF YOU
TEST NEGATIVE, YOU'VE HAD AN
EXPOSURE, YOU TEST NEGATIVE, YOU
TEST THE NEXT DAY.
AND YOU DO THAT FOR A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF DAYS AND TRY TO GET
PEOPLE IN THE GLASS ROOM AND
STAYING IN THE CLASSROOM.
I AGREE WITH DR. HOYEN, YOU
KNOW, CHILDREN HAVE TAKEN A
BEATING WITH THIS VIRUS AND
PANDEMIC.
AND THEY NEED TO GET BACK IN
SCHOOL.
AND THEY WANT TO BE BACK IN
THAT'S WHERE WE WANT THEM TO BE
AS WELL.
>> I WANT TO HEAR FROM BOTH OF
YOU IN TERMS OF WHAT YOU'RE
SEEING IN THE HOSPITALS.
YOU ARE SON THE FRONT LINES OF
COVID CASES IN KIDS.
AND THE AHEAD OF THE CDC
DR. ROCHELLE WALENSKY SAID
SOMETHING INTERESTING THIS
MORNING THAT GOT ALL OF OUR
ATTENTION, IN TERMS OF WHETHER
KIDS ARE SHOWING UP AT THE
HOSPITAL BECAUSE OF THEIR COVID
SYMPTOMS OR BECAUSE IT'S AN
INCIDENTAL PICKUP, ONCE THEY'RE
AT THE HOSPITAL.
SO LET ME PLAY THAT FOR YOU.
>> THIS IS A COMMON TIME OF YEAR
FOR CHILDREN TO BE ADMITTED IN
THE HOSPITAL.
AND SOME OF THE THINGS WE'RE
SEEING IN THE TRENDS THEY'RE NOT
HEADING TO THE ICU MORE OFTEN
THAT WE CAN TELL.
MANY OF THEM ARE ACTUALLY COMING
IN FOR ANOTHER REASON, THAT THEY
HAPPEN TO BE TESTED WHEN THEY
INCIDENTALLY TO HAVE COVID.
AND THIRD AND MOST IMPORTANTLY,
MOST OF THOSE CHILDREN ARE NOT
YET VACCINATED.
>> DR. HOYEN, DOES THAT TRACK
WITH WHAT YOU'RE SEEING?
>> YEAH, I THINK IN NORTHEAST
OHIO, WE'RE A LITTLE BIT BEHIND
THE CURVE IN TERMS OF WHAT OTHER
PLACES ARE SEEING.
SO I THINK WHAT WE'RE SEEING
STILL AT OUR CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL, AND AS WE GO THROUGH
THE NEXT WEEK, AS DR. KIMBERLIN
SAID, WE WILL BE LEARNING A LOT.
WE DO HAVE CHILDREN IN THE
HOSPITALS SIMPLY FOR COVID.
WE HAVE CHILDREN IN OUR ICUs
WITH COVID.
WE DO HAVE A COUPLE OF KIDS WHO
HAVE INCIDENTALLY TESTED
POSITIVE.
SO IT MAY BE THAT START OF THE
OMICRON THAT WE'RE SEEING WHERE
KIDS MAY BE RELATIVELY
ASYMPTOMATIC.
BUT, AGAIN, IT'S TOO EARLY FOR
US TO KNOW THE EXACT COURSE OF
WHAT WILL HAPPEN IN CHILDREN.
AND WE'LL BE KEEPING IN CONTACT
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES AROUND THE
COUNTRY TO BE SURE THAT WE'RE
DOING ALL WE CAN TO KEEP KIDS
SAFE WHILE WE'RE HERE.
>> HOW ABOUT YOU, DR. KIMBERLIN?
>> WELL, ACROSS MUCH OF THE
SOUTH, OUR DELTA WAVE RESEEDED
BY THE END OF OCTOBER, BEGINNING
OF NOVEMBER.
>> RIGHT.
>> SO, WE HAD A PRETTY NICE
PERIOD OF HANDFUL OF WEEKS JUST
AFTER THANKSGIVING.
NOW IN TERMS OF CASES, NOT
NECESSARILY HOSPITALIZATIONS,
BUT OUR CASES, IT'S ALMOST A
VERTICAL KIND OF LINE.
SO, REALLY, IT'S SOMETHING THAT
I ANTICIPATE WILL HAVE A LAG
PERIOD.
AND WE'LL START SEEING INCREASED
HOSPITALIZATIONS AS WELL.
EVEN IF, EVEN IF OMICRON IS A
LITTLE LESS, OR SOMEWHAT LESS
SEVERE, COMPARED WITH DELTA AS
AN EXAMPLE, IT IS SO MUCH MORE
INFECTIOUS.
AND THEREFORE, SO MANY MORE
PEOPLE ARE GETTING INFECTED.
OUR POSITIVITY RATES IN OUR
EMERGENCY ROOM AND OUR
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL HAS
INCREASED SEVEN-FOLD IN TWO
WEEKS.
AND SO EVEN IF THERE ARE NOT AS
MANY BEING ADMITTED, IN TERMS OF
LIKELIHOOD PER PERSON, YOU GET
SUCH A LARGE NUMBER, THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE MORE PEOPLE
ADMITTED.
AND SO, WE'RE WAITING FOR THAT,
AS DR. HOYEN SAID, WE'RE
WATCHING ANXIOUSLY.
THAT'S A NERVOUS ANXIOUSNESS, TO
SEE WHAT COMES.
>> DR. HOYEN, DID YOU WANT TO
QUICKLY ADD SOMETHING?
>> YEAH, I JUST WAS GOING TO SAY
TO HIS POINT EXACTLY, IT'S AS IF
WE'RE WATCHING THAT TRAIN COME
DOWN THE TRACKS, I THINK I SAID
THIS THE OTHER DAY AND NOT
TRYING -- YOU KNOW, HOPING IT
DOESN'T DERAIL.
JUST THE SHEER NUMBER OF
CHILDREN GETTING INFECTED, EVEN
IF A SMALLER PERCENTAGE OF THOSE
CHILDREN GET SICK, IT STILL
COULD BE VERY OVERWHELMING FOR
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS.